The simplest form of input
is just key presses.
They offer the user the tightest
control over the game.
And even if you're building a mobile
game where key presses aren't relevant,
they're still incredibly convenient for
debugging.
There are a couple different things you
might want to know about a key press.
Say you're building a platformer,
and you want to control the left or
right movement of your
character using the arrow keys.
Each frame, you check if the left or
the right key is pressed, and
then move the character in
the appropriate direction.
On the other hand, say you want
the character to fire a grappling hook
when the space bar is pressed.
In this case, you don't actually want to
check the state of the space bar every
frame, you're only interested in
the moment the key is pressed.
If the user holds down the space bar,
you don't care.
We have two different approaches,
one where we want to know the state
of the inputs every frame, and
one where we want to be notified
when certain things happen.
The former approach
is called pulling and
the latter approach is
known as event based input.
We'll start with pulling
as it's a bit simpler but
we'll get to even based
input later on in the level.